let's talk about solutions yeah what
does a regular person do
well the next story we have is from
washington times
five oregon counties to vote on leaving
the state and escaping to greater idaho
understandable and they actually have
two phases the first phase
is to get these five counties which
would turn idaho into a
coastal state it would give them a port
no joke no
way i know it would reach the the uh uh
pacific
i love it they also have phase two which
would rope in
northern california yes into greater
idaho
it would not create a new state and this
is this is their plan
so you have all these counties in oregon
which are conservative the oregon
these counties are saying the
politicians in
in in portland in oregon they're they're
they're all democrats right it's all the
democrat areas right they dominate the
state politics
and they're giving covet relief to their
constituents and ignoring the rural
areas
the rural areas say well we got more in
common with idaho how about the idaho
border move and encompass
us i like it too
one of one of the challenges they say is
have you guys heard of the state of
jefferson
yes northern california same thing
they think they should break off and
form a 51st state called jefferson
because they have nothing in common with
the rest of the state in the big cities
and they do not get represented the
problem is creating a new state
california is going to have to sign up
on giving up this territory the u.s will
have to have like a
article 5 convention or whatever it's
called where like all the states come
together and then vote for amendments
and that would create the new state the
same thing is true for greater idaho but
it would not change the amount of
senators
so there should still be the same amount
of congress men and women
and there should be the same amount of
senators and all it would do is move
some borders around which they say
does happen i'm a fan of i'm a fan and
you've got
sovereignty away from of course the big
socialist communist
very far leftist governments and and
super populated right i think
one of the big problems with northern
california is that there it's more
sparsely populated it's more rural and
so
not only are they going to be ignored in
terms of their political disposition
like they just don't have the political
capital
to be able to get the the people who are
making the decisions to care about them
right and with greater idaho obviously
that would that wouldn't be the case you
do have so much
surely so much more shared value and so
much more shared interest
i guess it would change the the house of
representatives for each of those states
presumably if enough people shifted and
moved but you're right it wouldn't
change the number of senators and it
probably like
california will lose what maybe one
congressional district
at most there yeah and so yeah i don't
know
i think this is such a great idea to
give a voice to some of the more rural
populations i'm so i don't know about
you guys but i'm super tired of the big
cities having all of the concentrated
power
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah and
so this one people need a voice
so the interesting thing is that there
was a study that came out recently that
said even
in red states the cities are blue yes
yeah
the issue is that in these blue states
the cities
are disproportionate in population size
to the rest of the state
in the red in the red states it's
inverted so
it'll be interesting to see all of a
sudden these counties that have
zero representation all of a sudden feel
represented that's great
i think it's a great idea because what's
the alternative yeah exactly
people if people feel like the
government does not represent them what
do they do yeah
this country was founded based on that
fact peacefully it's a great thing about
being in a democracy like this too or
republic
representative democracy is that you can
alter your borders peacefully
yeah here's the weird thing we've got
weld county colorado right
yes they want to be a part of wyoming
for the same reason
you got the state of jefferson even if
the people who live there say
we don't want to be a part of this place
anymore and we're the ones who live
there
we are the people who run this county
the state can still the state still has
to vote on whether you're allowed to
leave
yeah that makes no sense to me i don't i
don't think that should be why would a
state let you leave yeah
why would they be like we willfully give
up people who aren't slave taxes yeah
exactly exactly these are tax payers who
have no representation
who are funneling money to their
salaries and of course they're not going
to let their serfs leave
yeah example is the problem where those
people end up doing they get angry
you'll see protests they'll we've got to
have representation
it would be interesting to see if that
like just as a phenomena catches on
right forget like those individual
places for a second
if individual communities can say hey
look we share we are a hundred feet away
from another state that shares our
values and we are existing within a
state that doesn't
what are the sorts of things we can do
and animate to start to move and change
those things
um i think you could have that could be
a really really fascinating experiment
in federalism to see how that plays out
at a
all across the country look at how the
democrats want to make puerto rico and
washington d.c
states so they can get four more
senators yes and then have a uniparty
contr like a single party rule
controlling the country now to be fair
the republican party establishment
democratic party establishment
essentially the same things
but what what's happening now is the
democrats don't even want to bother with
whatever
you know pseudo arrangement they had in
the first place and they're like
hey we'll make two more states and then
we'll never lose ever again right
they would tell you oh jefferson can't
become a state that's ridiculous why it
would create two new republican senators
or maybe not i'm not confident what's
gonna happen to the republican party
i'm seeing all these these progressives
saying like joe biden bombed siri
instead of giving us checks
good luck in the midterms and i'm like
they don't need it the republican party
is split in
and is fractured right people they want
trump they want people who support trump
they do not want the crony establishment
so look we've had people on this show
who have mentioned the idea of peaceful
divorce yeah i think luke's mentioned
peaceful development
my the first time i came on the show i'm
like hey don't don't don't make fun of
me but i think memes
and peaceful divorce are going to be the
only solution that are going to cause
the least amount of harm
on people so if you want to reduce harm
you're going to have to work out a
solution where people peacefully move
away from each other and decide to live
next to each other and not aggress
against each other
well without a peaceful divorce like how
do we get to that point right
right and so i think we're seeing what
recall efforts we're seeing a lot of
people go after the governors and
complain about them
but we always try to vote out incumbents
and it doesn't change things for a lot
of people
that's why so many people who never
voted for voted before voted for trump
right
because they're thinking what's the
point it's not going to change anything
going back and forth well then someone
comes along and says
i got an idea how about we move this
town to a different state
okay that sounds pretty good so five
counties are
going to be voting on this in may
apparently in november several counties
voted to do it already not that i think
it will really happen
but they're saying we want this right
all right the states and the federal
government say no you can't do it
well these people are i mean what
happens because i talked about this
before
when you know joe biden or fauci says
here's our new you know covet guidance
and this town says we've had it yeah no
and they set up their own checkpoints
they said their police say we won't
force this already we're hearing in many
jurisdictions the
the sheriffs are saying they're not
going to enforce that stuff
what happens then when these people feel
like without representation i have no
confidence in the system anyway
in this in the in the state of jefferson
i'll do air quotes
that there are people who have flags for
the state of jefferson
they want it they demand it i guess in
the end
what we're seeing here is this will
start heating up and then eventually
you'll get to the point where when this
fails people say peaceful divorce
yeah i mean mr the mr potato head thing
was enough to get mark dice to say
time for republican states is a seed
from this a little hyperbolic
i know it's hilarious you must have
really loved mr potato yeah truly
so what's the plan with mr potato head
now not to diverge too far away are they
going to come in potatoes
you just made you just made a very big
mistake oh boy called the potato potato
mister
potato it is now just potato head no now
it is
just potato head or potatoes before it
was mr and mrs
potato head it's genderless and now
they're just both called potato head
yeah are they both genderless or is it
just
they're born with the central potato but
mr potato head comes with like eyelashes
and big lips yeah and the mesh potato
comes with the mustache oh but it's just
all gonna be packaged as potato head now
yeah
like so now you get i guess one with
everything in it
sounds like they might like not now now
they don't have to make different color
boxes
yeah with different designs they'll save
some money on design and box production
yeah but then it sounds like they're
going to be selling less products yeah
half as much product what if you did
like mr potato head mrs potato head
potato head kids
yeah we had date ahead potato head yeah
you can't do it
you could have i mean you could potato
dog a non-gendered potato head
you could do
hold on we're giving away really good
ideas i'm telling you i think i think
what this all was
as soon as i saw it at first i was like
well this is dumb and then my second
thought was
oh no there's some really creative
intern who said i can get potato head
trending
and his bosses are like yeah okay yeah
potato head hello
this has brought we have a potato head
for a good journey she's like listen
follow me here potato mr potato head
no gender do away with it watch what
happens boom now we're talking you know
the worst part was
when he was like he was at pitch meeting
where the intern was pointing to like
his slides and like as he's pitching the
the
no gender mr date head the other intern
was walking and holding the ipad with
potato dick and potato boobs
and then he hears he overhears him
saying it and he like you know
sadly he looks down and he mopes away
i was going to make mature potatoes yeah
exactly adult potatoes
it really squint it's a simulation so we
need to simulation
i'm done we've been making states since
1776 right
and so why don't we just keep making
them yeah well making states is hard
because the the political process around
it is tortured right the whole forever
there will always be a democratic push
to make washington dc estate the
argument will be the argument will
narrowly be
we should do like the implicit argument
is we should do this because we need to
enfranchise everyone
because they want two senators
republicans will make the opposite point
say hey this doesn't actually make sense
in the constitution
but fundamentally don't get me wrong the
whole from a uni party perspective
if it would have been two republicans
who got elected senators i guarantee you
the republican party would find a really
compelling reason
why we've been misreading the
constitution the democrats would be
saying the concept and they would be
saying the opposite thing and so
you'll always see that back and forth in
that fight about new states
the important reason we have dc is not a
state is so that the federal government
exists outside of any state's
jurisdiction we have to have that
puerto rico actually actually makes
sense to be a state yeah me too but and
like if but imagine if you could look at
uh
god i don't know what you would call it
between it was a jefferson state the
state of jefferson
if you could have the state of jefferson
and then part of oregon and say all
right here
this has like if you could cut out those
areas and make them have approximately
the population
puerto rico and say all right guys one
for one we're doing it yeah okay yeah i
think that'd be great
i don't think i don't think the dems
would probably not go for it only
because they would lose some
little bit of representation and all of
that and and california obviously drives
so much of the money
party but i don't understand the logic
behind
i'm not being represented in this state
so we are going to self-govern
and i'm saying but we can say no yeah
how does that make sense
the constitution is literally you know a
government of by and for the people
you know it is the duty of the people
blah blah blah all that stuff so what's
the justification now for the u.s
they're not leaving the country they're
not leaving the union right greater
idaho
is is crafted very politically in a very
smart way to say oh yeah it won't change
the amount of states
it will give idaho more representation
more uh congressional representation
actually no i don't think it would
actually change the break the makeup of
congress because
the jurisdictions for congress are not
are are are going to be based on like
the
sort of county level right well so
they'll be based on the 20 it's
interesting in terms of when it happens
it'll come down to the 2020 census but
no
it's a population question and so it
depends on how much how many people
greater idaho adds to current idaho well
so
the the the area of oregon that is going
to break off and join idaho
already has a republican representative
these districts oh good point
so they would join idaho it wouldn't
change yeah it would just mean that
state law would benefit them they'd be
able to have guns
they would get their coveted relief when
they needed it they would be respected
and represented is very smart what
they're proposing that's good point
i think it's a huge problem that oregon
can be like nah
well you're not representing their
people if they come to the federal
government and say
we object and we demand the right to do
this i think the federal government
should say agreed yeah i think so too
if idaho agrees idaho was the only one
who has to agree to this
the counties have to agree and idaho has
to agree oregon should have no say in
the matter
look tim it's there's too much common
sense for the government to do this ah
yeah so if it was ridiculous stupid and
counterintuitive
they would have their stamp on it right
away exactly but but it it
this makes a lot of sense this makes
perfect sense if we
lived in a just society where we had
government that actually served its
people
it would happen but again we have to
also understand that the government of
california the government of oregon
a lot of these bureaucrats view their
citizens as
tax cattle and tax slaves so they're not
going to want to give up people who
they're going to be able to tax and take
a huge amount of money for that they
don't have to do anything for
so the initiative of the government
that's already going bankrupt especially
in california that can't balance a
budget
that that can't that has so many
wasteful spending
bills and initiatives and programs that
are just absolutely ridiculous
they're not going to give away their tax
slaves they want them just like
just like in in ancient days with in the
roman empire they saw people
as money they and the people were
converted into slaves
that's the same thing that's essentially
serfdom yeah this is this is like a
neo-feudalist kind of thing yeah it is
these people with no representation are
paying taxes and that is money the state
will not give up now here's the funny
thing
when the the greater idaho people said
covet relief went to
the democrat constituents and not us
that's your
money yeah that's the money from the
conservatives who paid the taxes and
then saw
that tax revenue from the federal
government and from the state level go
to
their political rivals and was not
fairly allocated so would it have to be
that idaho buys the territory
from the other states no it's like
reparation for the
loss no i don't think i i think it
should literally just be
we live here yeah we voted the county
says
the the the council members whatever
represents this county yeah we are now
idaho but california could be like well
we
spent a lot of california citizens taxes
to make those cities what they are
so you owe us something before you leave
that's something that we need to be
adjudicated but that's the problem what
the people in greater idaho are saying
is that they're not
getting that they're not getting the
resources and so the argument from
someone in like portland was like well
you're gonna have to consider all the
taxes you've got to pay and they're like
the taxes would go down
yeah we would pay less in taxes i know
and you're not giving us the resources
so the problem is
the grievance they have is you're not
investing in us
you're not fixing our infrastructure or
giving us the coveted relief we've asked
for
you're giving it to your people who are
going to vote for you to maintain their
power
that is going to lead to conflict in
crisis
when one side is getting too little and
one side is getting too much
it's the hunger games so what makes
sense
if i live here i should be able to be
like we vote
there we go the land is this county
idaho what do you say
then idaho would have to vote right and
if idaho says yes
done yeah exactly and that i think in so
many ways too
that would help get around concerns if
you have these places that aren't paying
much in taxes that aren't super valuable
you would at least have to have buying
from the places they're going to say
yeah they're not just taking them in as
you know as the backstraggler or what
have you these are just
people who we want to break bread with
and so we are going to do what we need
to to legally empower them to be
citizens like us thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you